هكذا يبدو مدخل الساحه الحمراء عشيه
احتفال روسيا بالنسخه الثامنه والسبعين
لعيد النصر في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
تشديد امني وتواجد لعشارات العناصر
والاليات في كل مكان داخل مركز العاصمه
صراع روسيا مع الغرب القى بظلاله على واقع
العاصمه موسكو ملف المسيرات الضاربه خاصه
تلك التي حلقت فوق مبنى الكرملين حول
المكان الى سكنتين وفرض واقعه من القلق
لدى القائمين والشارع الروسي
من يخاف من الذئب يجب ان لا يدخل الغابه
ولا مهرب من المصير فالابتعاد عن مثل هذه
الاماكن خوفا من المسيرات غير مجد فهناك
سيارات في الشوارع وسكوترات قد تودي بحياه
الانسان نستمتع بوقتنا من دون ذره خوف
اجراءات الاستعداد تستمر منذ ايام اغلاق
للشوارع المجاوره لمبنى الكرملين لفتح
المجال امام الاليات المشاركه في العرض
العسكري وضع اعتده المواطن الروسي من قبل
لكن ليس بهذه الحده
لا توجد انظمه دفاع جوي تحمي بشكل كامل
القوات هنا في مهمه لحفظ الامن والوضع من
ايه اخطار
العاشره صباحا تسعي من ما هو موعد
الاحتفال بعيد النصر هذا المكان سيكون
حكرا على حاملي بطاقات الحضور هذه لكن مع
التدقيق والفحص الشديدين عبد الجواد
الروشت العربيه
موسكو لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات